death being like a song takes place over
time there's a beginning to it there's a
culmination and then there's an ending I
think it has the possibility of
enhancing our lives rather than taking
something away from them my name is Kate
Munger I'm the founder of the threshold
choir we sing at the bedsides of people
who are dying I started the first choir
in March of 2000 six months later two
more choirs and today there are 150
choirs around the world
in 1990 I spent an afternoon taking care
of a friend of mine who was dying of
hiv/aids
he was comatose and agitated and I
didn't know what to do so I started
instinctively singing to him he started
to calm and I started to calm I knew I
discovered something ancient and that I
wanted to bring back the songs that we
bring to bed sites are mostly songs that
we've written they're short they're some
very very softly and the lyrics offer
comfort they offer serenity they offer
simplicity and ease
we'll knock on the door and try to slip
in to the room where the person is dying
as gently as a butterfly I've come to
sing for you we often see a calming of
the breath sometimes we'll see a toe
tapping or a finger moving a smile and
then when we're done slip out just as
quietly often we'll leave singing many
of the people we've sung for say that
their pain is gone the pain is lessened
that is a miracle to me
you